hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a review of
it the Stephen King horror film directed
by Andy machete and rather than just ask
was it good or was it scary yes by the
way on both accounts in fact I just saw
it and now I'm recording this alone in
the studio at 3 in the morning a big
mistake in this video I'm gonna explain
the key device that made it so effective
and how we see it in each element of the
movie and while I don't intend to
straight-up spoil any major plot points
in the movie I will be covering aspects
that if you avoided all trailers and
consider any basic character detail to
be a spoiler then to cover my bases
spoilers ahead okay so with it both in
the novel and in this movie the reason
it's so powerful it makes you the viewer
decide what fear is most other horror
films are more one-sided hey here's the
thing that scares a lot of us isn't it
isn't it scary they tell us what to be
afraid of it could be a beast that
you're hunting that might sneak up on
you first it could be a sickness that
you might catch or it could be some
social anxiety like a woman not being in
control of her own body or a racial
minority being systemically targeted but
it is more of a conversation it
redefines fear as something subjective
something that looks different to each
of us why well because it's children we
each had unique traumas that messed us
up in different ways so in the story the
entity known as it is a shapeshifter it
manifests in two different forms
depending on whatever child it's feeding
on and what that kid is afraid of the
title it is literally the most ambiguous
anonymous pronoun it is a mirror
reflecting our own deepest darkest fears
and now that I've gotten a chance to see
it what's most impressive about this
movie is it goes out of its way to
visually reach out to you the viewer
sneaking out of the frame in very subtle
visible ways so that as you watch it and
you notice these little moments it's
almost like it is saying hey you no one
else is reacting to me right now but you
can see me it's your fear that I'm
feeding on so let's talk about how this
plays out with the characters okay the
main heroes of this story are the seven
members of the losers
bill Beverly Ritchie Ben Mike Eddie and
Stanley in the movie does such a good
job of characterizing these kids by the
things that frighten them for Bill it
takes the form of his little brother
Georgie losing him Huntsville the most
for Beverly it takes the form of sexual
trauma she's a victim of both real
sexual harassment and abuse and of all
the false rumors about her then there's
Richie he played by thin wolfhard Mike
from stranger things he's the comedian
of the group and he has the best lines
in the movie so it makes sense that the
clown an archaic to kid-friendly symbol
of comedy would be his enemy work then
it takes a form of the historical record
that He pours through in the library
which is a reflection of his greatest
fear social isolation for Mike it is the
trauma that he suffered as a child
losing his parents in a fire for Eddie
it takes the form of anything disgusting
the movie greywater a leper who appears
to him reflecting his hypochondria and
for Stanley his greatest fear is
disappointing his rabbi father so for
him it takes a form of a woman in a
painting in his father's office now here
I'm gonna get into some more specifics
in the clever visuals that the director
uses to bring these fears to life and if
you haven't seen the movie yet I
actually think it'll be fun for you to
keep an eye out for them but if you'd
rather stumble upon them on your own
skip to this time okay for Bill's fear
the director uses the image of rain to
trigger it you'll notice a single drop
of rain from a leak in the ceiling is
enough to blur bill back into this
memory of his lost brother meanwhile for
Beverly the image of blood has a
symbolic meaning early in the film
Beverly is seen buying tampons in the
pharmacy and then after the creepy
pharmacist hits on her and after her
father hints it sexually abusing her
blood explodes out of her sink and I
know this is kind of gross but it's
manifesting as Beverly's fear of sexual
maturity and then when Richie finally
reveals his fear of clowns at the 4th of
July event he looks across the park and
shudders when he looks at this clown now
I'm almost certain that that clown is
Bill skarsgård the actor who plays penny
wise he's just wearing different makeup
so it is appearing to Ricci in this
moment it also appears to Ritchie in the
house
later on when that clowns doll head
turns the background following him
across the room the director also sneaks
it in the background with Ben in the
library when Ben flips through the
pictures of the headless boy you might
notice the woman of the background
staring directly at him Rosen smiling
now the crazy thing about this is that
none of these kids ever notice or react
to these appearances and that's because
the director put them there for us this
is it inviting us to map our own fears
over him now I want to wrap up this
section on casting characters by talking
about Bill skarsgård as Pennywise a
clown he is fantastic in this movie he
actually does a very different route
than Tim Curry did in the it TV
miniseries in the 90s which will always
be a classic to me but skarsgård instead
tones down penny wise making him much
quieter in scaring us in more subtle
ways the coolest example of this are his
eyes check this out
one of scars guards eyes is pointed in
one direction while the other is pointed
directly at the camera you can tell
actually by covering each eye one of the
time this is actually an effect of the
director planned ahead of time and he
was gonna use CGI to do it but skarsgård
told him that he could actually do this
with his eyes naturally and he said well
I can do that you need like that and I
said good gentlemen you just saved me
hundreds of thousands of dollars and the
effect here is that it produces a meta
discomfort in us almost like penny wise
could pop out of the movie screen at us
just like the girl in the ring or like
how penny wise himself teases with the
fourth wall later in the movie the
trailer for this movie broke YouTube's
view records and I think a big part of
that was the nostalgia people our age
feel for past versions of it the book
the Tim Curry version I actually
remember walking through blockbuster as
a kid averting my eyes when I passed it
on the shelf I know right blockbuster
used to exist and I think by one of his
eyes staring at us through the lens it's
almost like this penny wise knows how
terrified we still are of this image and
he's toying with our own childhood
memories okay let's move on to another
form this interpretation of fear takes
the setting of the film the story of it
takes place in the fictional town of
Derry Maine in Stephen King's novel the
town of Derry has its own malevolent
history that this movie does touch on
the movie also resets the time period
from the 50s to the 80s which actually
gives the screen
new ways to express these kids anxiety
with hypochondriac Eddie freaking out
over the AIDS epidemic and new kid on
the block been worried that he'll be
judged for loving lame 80s pop music but
really I think the film gets more
mileage out of the fact that the town as
a whole is yet another manifestation of
fear for these kids the adults of dairy
are monsters you'll notice that none of
the adults in this movie acts like real
people they're all one-dimensional
violent and cruel they terrorize these
kids in fact for Beverly
Eddie Stanley Mike and Bill and the
bully Henry their parents directly
trigger their traumas and of course
there's that creepy pharmacist not that
guy and when Georgie and Ben are both in
danger at different points early in the
movie adults witness it and both times
they're in a position to help them and
they do nothing these adults are in
there in action just as monstrous as
penny wises so why does it film do this
transforming the adult characters into
treacherous set pieces is yet another
way that the director reinforces this
theme beer takes all forms and yes
sometimes that means that people who are
supposed to be protecting us did it work
literally did it I think Andy machete
proved that a tale of traumatized
children teaming up to conquer their
fears can totally work on its own we
love seeing it with stranger things so
it makes sense that we'd love it with
the Stephen King story that inspired
stranger things but in this case it
worked because the director took the
time to characterize each one of these
kids showing how fear takes a different
form for each one of them and by
inviting the viewer in with extreme
attention to detail so that the film
scares us and unique ways this is a
truly frightening film that I look
forward to seeing again and discussing
further honestly there was some amazing
shot composition and practical effects
here that I can't wait to analyze not to
mention the amazing performances by all
these young actors but ultimately it
owes its success mostly to its focus on
the core concept that Stephen King found
to be the scariest and most worthy of
exploration a word actually that
Pennywise exalts almost as a victory cry
in a key moment in this movie fear what
do you find scariest about this new
version of it and how do you think it
compares to the past version share your
reaction and your terrifying
hood memories about it in the comments
below or hit me up on twitter at EA boss
or two new rockstars add new rockstars
and if you really like us and want to
help us make more videos like this you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current patrons
especially Wilhelmina Edison thanks for
watching
I'm clearly exhausted so I'm gonna try
to sleep now do you guys hear something